if there's anything still standing in
the way of a direct sequel to 2018s Tomb
Raider it isn't the pandemic problems
with the script or scheduling with the
actors instead it's the fact that a
reboot to the franchise was announced in
early 2023 this stems from mgm's loss of
the rights following their acquisition
by Amazon with an apparent bidding war
taking place for the chance start from
scratch the winners of that bidding war
were of course Amazon who quickly
announced Grand plans for a total reboot
of the movie with a new actor taking
over for theander the deal was a big one
for the streaming service which includes
much more than just the rights to make a
feature film The Hollywood Reporter
suggested it only fell a little short of
their gargantuan deal for the Lord of
the Rings the announcement came on the
heels of the news that Amazon would be
getting into the video game publishing
business and it would be putting out the
next Tomb Raider console game from
developer Crystal Dynamics details at
this time are still sketchy